ja und hier sind im Blumentopf Prozent
die absoluten Super Reimar aus ein paar
Jahren
einen und Prozent sie sind auch über
einen der Bundesvision Song Contests
gelandet wie konnte das passieren
das Konto der Richter sehen dass wir aus
Bayern sind und
as schon so lange Musik macht es einfach
man derzeit war das wieder für Bayern
antreten durften und das machen wirklich
sehr gerne all die Jahre vorher dass er
gern hättet ihr sie gerne schon gemacht
um und hat die euch immer wieder
beworben Arbeitszeit nicht zum Zuge
gekommen hatte
der eigenen Währung sei wirklich damals
schon weiter voraus ich dass er zwar 90
nur mit dem Ziel gegründet jemals beim
bundesinnen- und das auch zu treten
der Grund zwar früher schon klar dass
es bald geben wird diesen Contest das
anders da was die bundes- und
Landesmitteln diese Nummer einiges
unsere Stimmung erreichte muss es ist
vollkommen neu aufstellen also von daher
sind wir jedenfalls sind dieses Jahr in
ihrem normalen Bundes müssen weil das
promi-dinner dieser schon ausgebucht war
bestimmt von der ASA com schreibt of the
Matter ohne Schwitzen besonders scharf
Kamer Schwyz und Uri z oo werden Heller
vom aber zu feige Erlanger e-werk
Bundesdurchschnitts gegen die Finnen
also ist das etwa 70 Prozent die Sendung
verdienen
klar dass das Areal an der Server der
Piratenpartei AG ändern würde sagte
Breuer
gut Prozent er rettete um
wie sind da die Chancen wenn er die
anderen Sachen
ein SID das recht den wir euch so aus
ja also wir haben
wir haben alles durchkalkuliert und um
es ist halt
die immer die Bayern stehen derweil am
Schluss halten würden auch wenn es die
Storyline vom Bund zu Song Contest ist
nicht unbedingt die Statistik dafür
spricht aber generell wenn man Tabelle
nimmt und Bayern nimmt es spricht für
die Statistik der Fürther die weit oben
zu landen aber es gibt ja auch er die
bunte Wege bist du bei Anproben sehen
musste die Tabelle drehen
das Thema
ja das stimmt schon aber bei den
Sechzgern es war
wer führt wer gewinnt nee das ist kein
Problem wir haben uns so Zentrum dass
Tuchel ließ sich vorbereitet auf denen
die Namen von ihnen
Bassist Thomas Tuchel mäßig
ja Wettringen Tucek Touristik ab wenn du
oben in der Tabelle stehen die es so bei
unserem Namen kennen
sollte der Name ihres Albums einfach mal
googeln Thomas Tuchel
d'fra gouf et gëtt dat ass tiptop das
verstehe ich jetzt nix
von Fußball der Vater arbeitet sehr gut
4 Prozent dann habe ich mich hiermit
Tell me offizielle outet um
aber trotzdem gibt es in Wetten oder
irgendwas Roman sondern fühlen kann man
sieht es ja so eine
um oder Gitter ist durch das scheißegal
er soll wir treten als die schon an mit
einem sportlichen mehr Ehrgeiz aber
fühlen kann ihnen nicht vorenthalten
werden Prozent
wir haben eben ein kraftvoller Stunde
ich zumindest - ich war über alle Bands
wie the Crackdown 2 habe ich mich schon
immer ganz groß gefühlt
es gibt ja viele unbekannte von dem aber
nichts gemerkt LG wir haben nichts
gemerkt aber noch nichts gehört hat
um
wir haben die überhaupt nicht schon
früher oder
um wieder die großen Namen Prozent
immer weiter vorne
30 ich glaube die sind alle schon für
überraschung gut die Blockflöte des
Todes ist für mich auf jeden Fall
verdient haben haben wir glaube ich alle
Angst
es hängt also wären keine Angst der
Erweiterung Grenzen Respekt massiv
dann Prozent Wünsche ihnen nicht nur
ich auch nicht Erfolg sondern wir haben
den stärksten youtube-kanal aus Bayern
dafür gewonnen 11 für euch Prozent
euch einzusetzen
die 8 und die Roma jetzt sehr ich hoffe
ihr freut euch ein wenig
«Es ist ein innerer Schuhplattler somit
ist eine kleine Beule an der
Schildescher dargestellt Hackl WSV 7
Prozent 6 fertig
alles
sie wird auf
4 Bild
später in der Nähe Macher von wollte
die wir sind froh dass wir da auch
Prozent
und dann platzten und an alle Bayern und
an alle die hier
nicht immer muss ich aber uns in die
Höhe dazu gehöre die solidarischen
bitte anrufen für uns für Blutdoper
Bayern dann feiern wir den
Bundesländern konnte sich Sven Rohde
Selma Lindner max-schmeling-halle